Générique
...
Bienvenue dans
"Ces idées qui gouvernent le monde."
Raymond Aron, une pensée phare
pour éclairer les conflits du monde.
Raymond Aron est né en 1905.
Il s'est éteint en 1983,
peu avant la chute du mur de Berlin
et l'effondrement
de l'Union soviétique.
C'est l'un
des plus féconds observateurs
des relations internationales.
Il est l'auteur d'une oeuvre
considérable sur un 20e siècle
qui met en exergue
les idéologies meurtrières
du communisme et du nazisme,
deux religions séculières
sur la classe et la race
qui causèrent des ravages humains.
A l'égal d'un Henry Kissinger
pour penser diplomatie et stratégie,
sur les pas de Clausewitz
pour démêler guerre et paix,
Raymond Aron
chercha à comprendre le monde
plutôt qu'à le transformer
selon des fantasmes bien-pensants
et révolutionnaires.
Doté d'un esprit de raison
et de valeurs libérales,
cet écrivain-journaliste
et conseiller des grands de ce monde
dont le général de Gaulle,
ne s'est quasiment jamais trompé
sur l'intelligibilité événementielle
du 20e siècle. Qu'on en juge.
Etudiant en Allemagne,
il perçoit d'emblée
ce que sera la barbarie nazie.
Il est contre le compromis honteux
et boiteux munichois en 1938.
Il rejoint la France libre en 1940.
Il met en garde contre l'idéologie
communiste et stalinienne.
Il est pro-européen convaincu.
Il soutient la réconciliation
franco-allemande, le marché commun.
Il se rallie à la décolonisation.
Il résiste même
à l'anti-américanisme
de la gauche française
et même du général de Gaulle.
Bref, des choix judicieux
dont il fait l'humble aveu.
Je le cite :
"Je n'ai jamais justifié
l'injustifiable
"pour raison dialectique."
Avec mes invités,
nous allons chercher à comprendre
ce parcours sans faute.
Nicolas Baverez,
vous êtes avocat,
politologue,
chroniqueur au Point et au Figaro.
Jean-Claude Casanova,
vous êtes économiste,
professeur des Universités
et directeur
de la revue Commentaire.
Sylvie Bermann,
vous êtes ambassadrice de France
et vous avez occupé quelques-uns
des plus beaux postes
diplomatiques.
Pierre Lellouche,
vous êtes ancien ministre,
essayiste.
Pierre Manent,
vous êtes philosophe.
Vous avez été l'assistant
de Raymond Aron
au Collège de France.
...
Pour Raymond Aron,
vous venez de le lire :
"La diplomatie
"des Etats démocratiques
obéit à d'autres règles
"que la diplomatie
des Etats totalitaires."
Hors de tout manichéisme
idéologique,
démocratie et totalitarisme
s'opposent radicalement.
D'où lui vient
cette sagacité politique
plutôt qu'à son époque,
l'air du temps
épousait plutôt le romantisme
sartrien de la violence ?
Dont on sait à quel point
il contribua
au brouillage de l'Histoire.
Nicolas Baverez.
-Ce qui est assez extraordinaire
chez Aron, c'est trois choses.
D'abord, une oeuvre qui est immense
et qui traverse les frontières
des disciplines,
à la fois philosophiques,
historiques,
une oeuvre de relations
internationales,
de stratégie et de sociologie.
Et il y a ce que vous avez rappelé.
C'est quelqu'un qui ne s'est
pratiquement jamais trompé,
qui a toujours été
du côté de la liberté.
Pour répondre à votre question,
c'est quelqu'un
qui a été extrêmement courageux
et qui a payé durement ses choix.
Pourquoi a-t-il compris
beaucoup mieux que d'autres
l'histoire du 20e siècle ?
C'est sûrement
le choc de ce qu'il a découvert
en Allemagne avec le nazisme
qui a été très important.
Il est allé en Allemagne en 1930.
Il part socialiste, pacifiste.
Et il voit arriver
Hitler au pouvoir.
Et là, il comprend d'emblée
que ce qui est
en train de se passer,
c'est quelque chose qui va faire
basculer l'histoire de l'Europe.
Il est d'emblée opposant au nazisme
et il abandonne son pacifisme.
A partir
de cette expérience fondatrice,
il découvre aussi la sociologie
allemande de l'histoire
et il va concevoir
à partir de sa thèse
le système intellectuel
qui va ensuite le guider
et qui en fera le professeur
d'hygiène intellectuelle
des Français.
C'est-à-dire un système
où il s'agit d'abord
de regarder
les faits comme ils sont,
de comprendre l'Histoire,
de l'interpréter
et de s'engager dans l'action.
Ce sera ensuite la fameuse position
du spectateur engagé.
C'est ce qu'il a utilisé
face à Hitler
et c'est pour ça
qu'il a été anti-Munichois,
qu'il s'est retrouvé aux côtés
du général de Gaulle à Londres
et c'est aussi pourquoi,
contrairement à l'essentiel
de l'intelligentsia française,
il est le seul avec André Malraux,
dans les grands intellectuels,
à être d'emblée, au moment
où la guerre froide se noue,
c'est-à-dire 46-47,
il est le seul
à être du côté de la liberté.
-Vous êtes tous d'accord ?
Il ne s'est jamais trompé ?
Jean-Claude Casanova ?
-Comparé à Malraux,
il ne s'est jamais trompé.
Malraux ne devient raisonnable
que dans la dernière
partie de sa vie.
Par exemple, Malraux approuve
le pacte germano-soviétique,
ce qui est quand même discutable.
Mais sur les grandes
questions politiques, non,
Aron ne s'est jamais trompé.
Et même, il ne s'est jamais trompé
avant les autres.
Par exemple, sur la nécessité
de l'indépendance de l'Algérie,
il l'a dit très tôt,
très clairement et très justement.
-Sylvie Bermann ? Pierre Lellouche ?
-Oui et en plus,
il a été très courageux.
Comme l'a dit Nicolas Baverez,
la tendance
était plutôt à gauche à l'époque,
pour ne pas dire gauchiste.
D'abord, le soutien
à l'Union soviétique
et puis également, au maoïsme.
Dans son combat avec Sartre,
certains avaient dit :
"Mieux vaut avoir tort avec Sartre
"que d'avoir raison
avec Raymond Aron."
Et tous les étudiants
en sciences politiques
et ensuite, les diplomates,
puisque je représente ici aussi
la diplomatie,
ne sont pas nés
gaulliens ou aroniens,
mais le sont devenus
de toute façon.
Parce qu'effectivement,
ce n'est non pas le monde
tel qu'on le désire,
mais le monde tel qu'il est
et une analyse des situations
à partir de cela.
-Pierre Lellouche ?
-Moi, j'ai eu la chance
de le rencontrer.
Malheureusement,
de façon trop courte,
c'était les quatre
dernières années de sa vie.
Mais il a joué un rôle
extrêmement important dans ma vie.
Je revenais
de mes études aux Etats-Unis.
J'ai réalisé
que personne ne voulait de moi.
Mon diplôme américain
ne valait rien
et il fallait tout recommencer.
Je n'avais pas envie de faire l'ENA.
Et il m'a pris avec lui
à la Maison des Sciences de l'Homme.
Il avait une générosité formidable
à l'égard d'un jeune.
Tous les mois,
nous déjeunions au Récamier.
et on parlait politique
et politique internationale.
Ce que j'adorais chez lui,
c'était non seulement
son goût de la liberté
et de la réalité des faits,
mais surtout,
l'extraordinaire clarté de l'exposé.
C'est ce que
nous rêvons tous d'obtenir :
commencer sur une feuille blanche
et amener le lecteur
à une compréhension des faits
et à la bonne conclusion.
Et ça, il savait le faire
d'une façon extraordinaire
grâce à la richesse de sa formation.
Philosophe, sociologue...
Je ne connaissais
qu'une petite partie du Aron, celle
des arts nucléaires
et de la stratégie
où il égalait
les plus grands aux Etats-Unis,
Bernard Brodie, etc.,
l'un des pères de ce qu'a été
la doctrine de la dissuasion,
de la négociation
sur les armes stratégiques.
Moi, il m'a tout appris.
Ce que j'avais appris
aux Etats-Unis, coloré par Aron.
Il a donc joué un rôle
très important dans ma vie.
Il y a eu la création de l'IFRI,
Jean-Claude s'en souvient.
Et puis après, j'ai bifurqué.
Ce qu'il n'a jamais voulu faire lui
et c'était l'une
de nos conversations.
Pourquoi être
seulement un spectateur
et pas un acteur de la politique ?
Moi, j'ai bifurqué.
-On va en parler.
Vous, Pierre Manent,
vous l'avez connu
également comme étudiant,
si je puis dire.
En tout cas,
vous avez été son assistant.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a conduit
à être son assistant ?
C'est vous qui avez choisi
ou c'est lui qui vous a choisi ?
-Je ne sais pas répondre
directement à votre question,
mais ce qui m'a frappé chez Aron
et ce qui continue de me frapper,
c'est le sérieux avec lequel
il considère la politique.
Parce que contrairement
à ce qu'on pense, c'est très rare.
Tout le monde
a son avis sur la politique,
s'enthousiasme pour ou contre,
mais les gens
ne s'intéressent pas véritablement
à ce dont il s'agit.
Si vous prenez Sartre,
il a souvent dit n'importe quoi
avec plus ou moins de brio,
parce que lui
ne s'est jamais vraiment
intéressé aux questions politiques.
Il prenait des positions
qui déduisaient d'une certaine
philosophie morale générale,
d'une certaine métaphysique,
mais la chose politique
ne l'intéressait pas.
Aron,
depuis le début,
il a regardé avec une attention
et une humilité extrême
de quoi il s'agissait.
Et donc, il nous donne à sentir
le caractère déterminant
de la chose politique.
C'est quelque chose qu'Aron
a en commun avec
les grands philosophes politiques
et avec les Grecs :
ce qui donne forme à la vie commune,
c'est d'abord la chose politique.
Et la chose politique
a sa propre noblesse.
Les gens
ont tendance à faire tomber
la morale sur la politique.
Mais il y a une morale
de la politique qui est,
d'une certaine façon,
l'une des plus difficiles,
car le politique
doit prendre en compte
des paramètres très différents.
-Comment
le philosophe que vous êtes
explique-t-il cette relation intime
qu'il avait
avec la chose politique
dont vous êtes en train de parler ?
-Je crois que
c'était la passion du citoyen.
Il avait une passion de citoyen
et une impartialité de philosophe,
si vous voulez.
C'est la jonction des deux
entre la passion du citoyen
et l'impartialité du philosophe
qu'il réussissait à combiner.
-Jean-Claude Casanova ?
-Tout se combine chez lui dès lors
qu'il choisit comme vocation
la réflexion sur l'Histoire
et que l'Histoire,
c'est à la fois
le passé et le présent
et que le passé et le présent
déterminent la façon
dont on voit l'avenir.
Il fait deux choses
très importantes en politique,
c'est qu'il ne cesse pas d'étudier
de 1933 à la fin de sa vie.
Il a étudié
toutes les grandes questions
nécessaires au jugement politique.
Il pouvait parler de la balance
des paiements
et des taux de change flexibles
comme de la dissuasion nucléaire,
du système international
ou de l'Union soviétique.
Et en deuxième lieu,
il avait une caractéristique
très importante
qui lui venait
d'un incident de jeunesse.
Quand il critiquait
une position politique,
il disait en même temps
ce qu'il serait nécessaire
ou possible de faire.
C'est-à-dire
que ses critiques étaient toujours
accompagnées
des autres voies possibles
qui lui semblaient plus judicieuses
ou plus raisonnables.
-Nicolas Baverez ?
-Pour prolonger
ce qu'a dit Jean-Claude Casanova,
quand il était en Allemagne,
il est revenu
et par l'intermédiaire
du frère d'un de ses amis,
il a eu rendez-vous avec M. Paganon,
sous-secrétaire d'Etat
aux Affaires étrangères,
qui l'a interrogé sur l'Allemagne.
Il a fait un super exposé
sur la situation de l'Allemagne.
Puis, M. Paganon,
qui n'était pas un aigle politique,
lui a dit :
"A ma place,
qu'est-ce que vous feriez ?"
Et là, il s'est retrouvé coi.
Il a toujours retenu ça
avec l'idée que
lorsqu'on parle de politique,
il faut...
ce qui a été dit, c'est-à-dire,
il faut analyser les faits,
la situation,
mais ensuite, se mettre à la place
des acteurs. Et effectivement,
chez Aron, il y a cette rencontre
entre un vrai projet intellectuel
qui était d'analyser,
de comprendre l'Histoire,
tel qu'elle se fait,
en en prenant en compte
toutes les dimensions, économiques,
stratégiques, politiques,
évidemment, mais aussi de comprendre
du point de vue des acteurs
et de s'engager ensuite.
Donc, de prendre
le risque de l'engagement.
-Oui, Pierre Lellouche ?
-Oui, mais de s'engager,
sans aller
jusque dans l'action politique.
Je me souviens d'une conversation
où je lui disais, avec beaucoup
d'admiration dans les yeux :
"Mais pourquoi vous êtes-vous
contenté d'un rôle engagé,
"mais de spectateur,
de commentateur."
J'ai cité Kissinger.
"Pourquoi n'êtes-vous pas devenu
"le Kissinger de la France ?"
On aurait eu besoin
de cela en France.
Dieu sait que...
Je ne vais pas faire de mauvais
commentaires sur le présent, mais...
Et là, il me dit :
"Ah non, ce sont deux choses
très différentes que l'analyse
"et l'action."
Et en me disant,
je sentais quand même dans ses yeux
le regret.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a l'action,
mais c'est l'action des idées,
pas rentrer dans l'arène politique
et se colleter
avec toute la difficulté
de l'action politique,
celle qu'on apprend
dans l'arène,
et qu'on réalise la difficulté
d'aller du point A au point B.
Mais il savait donner les moyens
d'action aux politiques. Après,
il fallait être écouté.
Il n'a jamais voulu
d'un rôle actif de conseiller.
Au début, vous disiez qu'il avait
été le conseiller du président
ou du général de Gaulle.
Je parle sous le contrôle...
-Il a influencé de Gaulle
sur l'Alliance atlantique.
On en a des preuves.
-Au moment du RPF, oui.
-Mais il n'a pas été
au quotidien à ses côtés
sur ces dossiers-là.
-Non.
-Pierre Manent,
je vous laisse la parole,
mais j'aimerais
que vous prolongiez le débat.
Dans cette émission,
on va faire des allers-retours
entre Raymond Aron et son siècle
et le siècle d'aujourd'hui.
La question
que je voudrais vous poser,
et vous répondrez par ailleurs
à cette dissociation
entre l'action et la pensée,
à son époque, déjà,
André Malraux et Jorge Semprun
pointaient la menace islamiste
et Jorge Semprun disait même
dès les années 60 qu'il s'agissait
"d'un totalitarisme vert"
qu'il mettait à l'égal
du stalinisme et du fascisme.
Qu'en aurait pensé Aron,
qui intégrait dans sa pensée,
ça a été souligné
par Jean-Claude Casanova
et Nicolas Baverez,
un spectre très large
de connaissances,
notamment religieuses,
économiques et sociologiques ?
-Je vais vous répondre
tout de suite
que je ne peux pas vous répondre.
Je ne sais pas ce qu'Aron dirait.
Ce dont je me souviens,
c'est que dans les premières pages
d'un texte particulièrement
intéressant d'Aron des années 60,
"L'Aube de l'histoire universelle",
il dit que finalement,
ce qui sépare le plus les hommes,
c'est peut-être l'idée
qu'ils se font les uns les autres
du sacré.
Il ne commente pas au-delà,
mais on peut penser
que dès ce moment-là,
en quelque sorte,
il envisageait
les distances entre les formes
de vie collectives. Après tout,
c'était un grand lecteur
de Weber
qui a été particulièrement intéressé
au rôle des grandes religions
dans la mise en forme
des vies humaines.
Donc, je pense que les circonstances
l'auraient conduit à s'y intéresser.
Mais quant à imaginer
ce qu'il en aurait dit,
je ne sais pas.
Je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il aurait spécialement apprécié
l'utilisation du terme
de "totalitarisme"
pour définir les problèmes
qui se posent à nous avec l'islam.
Mais ça...
-Vous vouliez dire un mot
sur la dissociation
entre praxis et...
-Oui.
Bien sûr,
il n'est pas passé dans l'action,
mais il avait sur la politique
le point de vue de l'action.
Il considérait que la politique,
c'était d'abord
des hommes agissants.
D'où l'importance
qu'il accordait au commandement.
Cela m'a frappé lors de la thèse
d'un de mes étudiants
qui rassemblait des éléments
sur la politique d'Aron.
J'ai mesuré à quel point
la notion de commandement
est fréquente dans l'oeuvre d'Aron.
Or, cette notion
a complètement disparu
de la compréhension
de la chose politique.
La démocratie ne s'intéresse
qu'à l'obéissance à la loi,
l'obéissance légitime,
mais que la politique soit faite
par des hommes qui commandent
et qu'elle soit déterminée
par ceux qui commandent
et par le style de leur
commandement, c'est son expression,
ça, c'est quelque chose
de spécifique
et c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle
il est si pénétrant
sur la chose politique.
-On revient
au fondamentalisme vert ?
-Pour poursuivre ce que dit Pierre,
voici une anecdote.
En novembre 1954, j'étais étudiant
et j'ai demandé à Aron
son avis sur un livre.
Et il m'a dit :
"Les livres de professeurs
sont parfois utiles
"pour préparer les examens,
mais si l'on s'intéresse
"à la politique,
il y a deux livres essentiels :
""La Guerre du Péloponnèse"
"de Thucydide
et "La Politique", d'Aristote."
Et si je me réfère à ces deux livres
et la citation d'Aron
que vous avez évoquée,
Aron trouverait
parfaitement idiot aujourd'hui
de considérer
que les différences
de régimes n'ont pas d'importance
et que les Etats
sont des monstres froids
qui ont entre eux
des rapports mystérieux
que ne comprennent
que les réalistes.
En fait, la différence entre Poutine
et l'Occident, c'est que la nature
du régime politique russe
est fondamentalement différente
des démocraties.
Et la différence qui se pose
dans le Moyen-Orient, c'est que
l'islam est en situation complexe
à l'égard de l'Occident
dans lequel le ressentiment
se mêle à d'autres.
Comprendre la politique,
c'est réfléchir à la nature
des régimes politiques,
à la différence entre les religions,
aux idées des hommes.
-Oui, Nicolas Baverez.
-Il y a un événement
sur lequel Aron s'est prononcé
et qui montrait qu'il a bien compris
la dimension religieuse,
c'est la révolution iranienne de 79.
A l'époque,
beaucoup de gens ont pensé
que c'était la suite
de la poussée de l'Union soviétique.
Et lui n'a pas du tout adhéré
à cette analyse.
Il a bien vu que c'était
une révolution religieuse.
Aron a toujours bien fait la...
A cette occasion, le départ
dans les idéologies totalitaires.
Il avait utilisé,
notamment à Londres,
la notion de
"religions séculières",
parce que c'était
la dimension de la foi,
la déification
de la race ou de la classe.
Mais il a toujours
bien fait la différence
entre les religions séculières
et les religions régulières.
Il n'a jamais avancé l'idée
que les religions régulières
n'auraient plus de poids
dans la politique.
De toute manière,
il y a un autre
dossier international
sur lequel il avait écrit
et il l'avait évidemment perçu,
c'est le Moyen-Orient
sur lequel on ne peut pas,
et on le voit aujourd'hui,
il n'y a pas d'analyse possible
ni de construction de solution
sans prendre en compte
le fait religieux, évidemment.
-Sylvie Bermann, avec vous,
voyons un aspect diplomatique.
Aron a dit dans "Guerre et Paix"
que le déclin historique
des nations européennes
a été précipité
par les guerres du 20e siècle.
Etes-vous d'accord avec jugement ?
Et était-il pessimiste
toute sa vie sur la possibilité
que l'Europe devienne
une Europe puissance ?
-Pour l'Europe puissance,
c'était un peu prématuré.
Mais néanmoins,
il était profondément Européen.
Même s'il croyait
à la souveraineté des Etats,
il pensait que l'Europe
avait un rôle à jouer.
Maintenant, est-ce que les guerres
du 20e siècle qu'il a connues
et qui sont les pires
ont précipité le déclin ?
Je crois qu'après ces guerres,
il y a eu l'espoir d'un renouveau.
Ce sont les Occidentaux
qui ont créé les Nations Unies,
dont il parle assez peu,
si je me souviens bien,
puisqu'il croit essentiellement
en la puissance des Etats
et non pas
à une instance internationale.
Et à l'époque,
c'était la guerre froide
et l'ONU était paralysée
comme elle est paralysée
aujourd'hui.
Donc, effectivement,
il croyait plutôt
au rôle des nations.
Mais encore une fois,
ces guerres ont été ravageuses
pour l'Europe,
mais à partir de là,
les Européens ont voulu
construire un autre système,
la réconciliation
avec l'Allemagne qu'il a soutenue
et un système européen.
-Pierre Lellouche,
vous allez répondre là-dessus,
mais prolongeons aussi la question
sur ce déclin de l'Europe.
Est-ce qu'il faisait un lien
entre déclin de l'Europe
et décadence de l'Occident ?
Autrement dit, est-ce
qu'il amarrait complètement l'Europe
à l'Occident ?
-Complètement, oui.
Il faut rappeler qu'il meurt
un an avant
la chute du mur de Berlin.
Donc, le monde qu'il a commenté,
c'est un autre monde.
Je le regarde presque
avec nostalgie
par rapport à ce que
nous vivons aujourd'hui
et aux chocs invraisemblables
qui sont devant nous.
Lui, il avait à faire à une Europe
qui s'était suicidée
à deux reprises au 20e siècle.
Il considérait
avec beaucoup de réalisme,
contre Sartre,
d'autres et les communistes,
que la solution était
de s'amarrer aux Etats-Unis,
sinon l'Union soviétique
prendrait tout le continent
et qu'il fallait éviter
la neutralisation de l'Allemagne.
Donc, il prenait les choses réelles.
Rappelez-vous,
le début des années 80 est dominé
par l'affaire des euros-missiles.
Si les Russes l'avaient emporté,
l'Allemagne était neutralisée.
On a tenu bon jusqu'à
la chute du mur. L'Union soviétique
se désagrège
deux ans après et là,
on bascule dans autre chose.
Mais il n'est plus là
pour le commenter.
Cela veut dire que la montée
de toutes sortes d'autres problèmes
comme l'islam qui était couvert
par les empires pendant la guerre
froide. Beaucoup de problèmes
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
avec le fameux sud global,
la revendication, le révisionnisme
venu du sud, de l'islam
et d'autre chose, n'existaient pas
pendant la guerre froide.
Il y avait deux empires.
Lui, il disait carrément
qu'il fallait tenir bon
face à l'Union soviétique.
Il a défendu l'alliance
avec les Etats-Unis
à une époque
où ça n'était pas facile.
De Gaulle essayait
de dégager des marges d'indépendance
pour la diplomatie française
entre les deux blocs
et toute une partie
de la classe politique française
était à fond antiaméricaine
et plutôt prosoviétique.
Il a tenu ce discours de raison.
-Nicolas Baverez ?
-Vous êtes d'accord avec ça ?
-Oui.
Dans "L'Opium des intellectuels",
Aron montre bien que l'Occident
est indissociable
de deux idées qui lui sont chères,
l'idée de la liberté
et l'idée de la raison.
C'est quand l'Occident
se brouille avec ces idées
que les problèmes arrivent.
Donc, c'est vrai que le 20e siècle
a été celui du suicide de l'Europe
et ce sont les Etats-Unis
qui ont fait la décision
dans les trois guerres mondiales,
y compris sur la fin
de la guerre froide.
Et Aron a aussi vu
l'apogée de l'Amérique,
ce qu'il a appelé
"la République impériale",
et puis, c'est le début
de ses difficultés.
Ce qui est très important,
c'est qu'il a construit
à partir de là une défense,
mais une défense
argumentée et critique
de la démocratie
en n'ignorant pas ses faiblesses
ou ses vulnérabilités,
mais en expliquant pourquoi
elles devaient être défendues :
parce que c'était le seul moyen
d'assurer la dignité des hommes
et surtout, en gardant l'espoir.
Ca a été rappelé,
Aron meurt en 83, donc juste six ans
avant l'effondrement
de l'Union soviétique.
Mais Aron, y compris dans
les périodes les plus difficiles,
a toujours gardé la foi
dans la démocratie.
En juin 39, il disait :
"Je crois à la victoire finale
des démocraties,
"mais à une condition,
"c'est qu'elles le veuillent."
Il y a toujours cet engagement
et aussi cette confiance,
cet acte de foi dans la liberté
et dans la capacité des citoyens
à se mobiliser.
Il reconnaît que
les démocraties sont traversées
par bien des contradictions.
Il sait, comme Tocqueville,
qu'en cas de guerre,
ça démarre mal pour les démocraties
parce que c'est des régimes
qui sont pacifistes
et qui sous-estiment
les menaces extérieures.
Mais il a foi dans leurs ressources
et dans leur capacité à se mobiliser
au moment où les choses vont mal.
Et c'est évidemment exactement
la situation dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui.
-Sylvie Bermann,
je sais qu'on ne peut pas parler
à la place d'Aron
et lui faire commenter le présent.
Mais essayons.
Henry Kissinger qui est décédé
à la fin de 2023,
dans une dernière interview
dans The Economist,
à la question posée
"Seriez-vous favorable à ce
que l'Ukraine adhère à l'OTAN ?"
a répondu "oui".
-Après avoir dit "non"
très longtemps.
-Oui, c'est vrai.
Mais il y a adhéré. A votre avis,
qu'aurait pensé Aron ?
Parce que...
Nous sommes là
avec une menace en Europe.
Je ne vous demande pas
de parler à la place d'Aron,
mais selon vous,
au regard de ce qu'il a écrit,
de ce qu'il a dit,
de sa défense de l'Europe,
de l'Occident, etc. ?
-En même temps, je voudrais ajouter
à ce qu'a dit Nicolas Baverez
qu'il croyait
à la force de l'Occident,
mais qu'en même temps,
il ne pensait pas
que l'Union soviétique
allait s'effondrer
et prônait
le maintien de la communication
avec l'Union soviétique.
Ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
"la déconfliction" pour éviter...
-En rappelant
que c'était l'Union soviétique.
-Voilà. Donc, aujourd'hui,
je ne sais pas.
C'est très compliqué
parce que pour l'Ukraine,
adhérer à l'OTAN
alors qu'elle n'a pas de frontières,
qu'elle a une partie occupée,
c'est impossible.
D'ailleurs, le gouvernement
américain ne l'a pas écouté
puisqu'il s'est opposé à l'adhésion,
de l'Ukraine à l'OTAN.
Un jour, peut-être,
mais je ne peux pas parler
à la place de Raymond Aron
qui était aussi
très largement
l'homme de la guerre froide,
même s'il avait perçu
que la géopolitique
allait s'élargir à d'autres pays.
Et c'était à la suite
des colonisations.
Désolée de vous décevoir,
mais il est difficile
de parler pour les morts.
...
Alors, vous venez de voir
ce qui s'est inscrit,
cette citation de Raymond Aron :
"Si les philosophes
ont souvent appelé l'homme
"à naître raisonnables,
ils ont rarement appliqué
"avec la même assurance
ce qualificatif
"à l'histoire des hommes."
Raymond Aron avait une méfiance
aussi réfléchie qu'instinctive
envers l'irrationalité
de l'Histoire.
A votre avis, d'où venait
cette méfiance chez lui.
Craignait-il la puissance
des forces irrationnelles,
la violence,
les passions des foules ?
Nicolas Baverez ?
-Ce n'est pas qu'il les craignait,
mais il les reconnaissait
pour ce qu'elles sont.
Quand on regarde
"Penser la guerre, Clausewitz",
on a bien ce mouvement
entre, d'un côté,
on l'a rappelé,
le rôle des leaders,
des dirigeants politiques,
des stratèges.
Ensuite, il y a des processus
historiques qui sont très longs.
Puis il y a
les passions des peuples.
Dans ces passions des peuples,
il y a la passion nationale,
parfois des passions collectives
qui les embarquent
du côté du racisme,
ce qu'on a vu avec l'Allemagne.
Et aujourd'hui, on le voit aussi
avec des passions religieuses.
Donc en fait, Aron nous explique
justement comment essayer de réagir
et comment essayer
de préserver la liberté politique
dans ces environnements
qui sont
des configurations changeantes.
Pour répondre à la question
que vous posiez tout à l'heure,
dans le système d'Aron,
il y a le système international,
les Etats et les sociétés.
Les Etats sont les pivots. Et donc,
il y a bien
cette reconnaissance du fait
que l'Histoire est faite
de projets, de visions, de raisons
et qu'il faut défendre
la raison et la liberté,
mais qu'elle est faite
aussi des passions.
Pour revenir à l'époque présente
et à cette idée
que les hommes sont raisonnables,
en 1960, à Londres,
il a prononcé une conférence
assez extraordinaire
sur l'aube de l'histoire
universelle
où, d'une certaine manière,
il anticipe la fin
de l'Union soviétique
en montrant que les hommes
vont être dans la même
histoire universelle,
celle que nous vivons.
Il termine la conférence en disant :
"Jamais les hommes n'ont eu
"autant de raisons
de ne plus s'entretuer,
"jamais ils n'ont eu autant
de raisons de travailler ensemble.
"Mais l'histoire universelle
sera-t-elle pacifique ?
"Sans doute pas."
Il finit ainsi :
"L'homme est un être raisonnable,
"mais les hommes le sont-ils ?"
On a bien cette nature
et cet espoir que la raison finisse
par pouvoir réconcilier les hommes,
mais que la réalité,
c'est que les passions
doivent être reconnues
pour ce qu'elles sont.
-Justement, sur ce point,
Pierre Manent.
Entre l'homme raisonnable,
l'histoire irrationnelle,
rejoint-il en quelque sorte Freud
qui disait que l'homme,
dès qu'il va vers la multitude,
il n'y a pas d'autre choix
que de s'entretuer
et aux civilisations,
de s'autodétruire.
Comment expliquez-vous...
-Je ne pense pas
qu'Aron dirait ce genre de choses.
-Oui,
mais n'est-il pas
sur cette même lignée ?
-Non, mais il n'a jamais rêvé
de la paix universelle.
-Il était kantien, pourtant.
-Oui,
beaucoup moins qu'on ne le dit.
Il était plutôt
aristotélicien ou thucydidéen.
Il partait de la pluralité
des corps politiques,
donc nécessairement,
comme les hommes ne réalisent
leur humanité que dans
des corps politiques distincts,
nécessairement,
ces corps vont être entre eux,
dans des relations
soit d'amitié, soit d'hostilité.
Et il pensait
que cette fragmentation
de l'humanité
était insurmontable
et d'une certaine façon,
qu'elle ne doit pas
être surmontée.
La seule façon de le surmonter
serait d'avoir un Etat mondial qui
serait nécessairement despotique.
Si on désire la liberté,
on doit accepter
le risque de la vie politique,
le risque de communauté distincte
qui ont chacune
non seulement des intérêts,
mais comme Aron
l'a toujours souligné,
ce sont moins les intérêts
qui séparent les hommes
que leurs idées du bien
et leurs opinions.
On peut s'accorder que toute guerre
est contre les intérêts
de tout le monde.
Mais ce n'est pas pour cela
que cela empêchera les hommes
de se battre. Donc,
les paramètres de la vie humaine
sont à la fois les intérêts,
les opinions, les passions,
l'horizon
d'une humanité réconciliée,
mais la réalité
d'une humanité fragmentée.
Et c'est avec tout cela
que l'homme politique,
le citoyen doit se débrouiller.
Donc, Aron ne s'est
jamais laissé emporter
par une solution qui viendrait
malgré nous, en quelque sorte,
parce que l'Histoire
nous conduirait à la réconciliation,
parce que le commerce
nous conduirait à la paix.
Au bout du compte,
ce sont des hommes
avec des opinions distinctes,
des passions sans lesquelles
ils ne vivraient pas
et puis des incertitudes
que l'on ne peut ôter
de la vie humaine.
Donc, il gardait
une vue dramatique, si vous voulez,
de l'existence humaine.
Je reviens d'un mot à l'Europe
dont nous parlions.
Il me semble me souvenir
qu'un des points
qui revenait sous sa plume
quand il parlait de l'Europe,
il était surpris de voir
à quel point l'Europe était devenue
spectatrice
de ce qui se passait dans le monde.
Elle était au balcon de l'Histoire
et il ne comprenait pas
qu'elle laisse à ce point l'action
aux Etats-Unis
ou aux autres puissances.
Je crois qu'aujourd'hui,
nous nous posons
encore cette question.
-Pierre Lellouche ?
-Je partage totalement ce que
Pierre Manent a dit et j'ajouterais
un ou deux éléments.
Le premier, c'est que
c'était l'homme de son époque.
C'était quelqu'un qui avait connu
la guerre, la montée du nazisme,
et qui avait connu la guerre.
C'est une très grande différence
de cette génération
qui est aussi celle
de Mitterrand,
de Charles de Gaulle.
Quand vous comparez ça aux leaders
et aux dirigeants actuels,
pas seulement en France,
mais en Europe,
et que vous voyez
comment ils se comportent
dans une affaire
aussi grave que l'Ukraine,
le basculement du monde
que nous vivons, il y a un problème.
On a l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas
la profondeur historique
et ressemblent aux somnambules
de Christopher Clark
au moment
de la Première Guerre mondiale.
Ils n'ont juste
pas compris ce qu'il se passe.
C'est l'impression que j'ai
et qui m'effraie.
Les gens comme Aron,
Mitterrand ou de Gaulle
qui ont vécu cette période
ont intériorisé l'idée
que des peuples peuvent disjoncter,
faire la guerre,
que ça peut être très violent.
C'est la réalité.
La conséquence de cela,
c'est qu'il a fabriqué,
il a été un de ceux
qui ont construit
ce qu'on appelle "l'école réaliste"
des analyses
de la politique internationale.
Kissinger se reconnaît en Aron
parce que ce sont des gens,
dont je fais partie,
d'autres ici aussi,
qui analysent le monde tel qu'il est
et pas tel que M. Kouchner
aimerait qu'il soit
avec son sac de riz sur l'épaule.
La France n'est pas une ONG.
On ne vit pas dans le monde
des Bisounours
On est devant des rapports de force
très complexe,
avec en plus l'apparition
de tout un tas de méchants
révisionnistes qui,
profitant de la fin
de la guerre froide,
du ratage de l'après-guerre froide,
sont en train
de faire exploser le système.
Et là, on peut se désespérer
de voir dans quel état
l'Europe se trouve aujourd'hui.
Et je pense qu'Aron
multiplierait les papiers
très durs sur : "Mais qu'êtes-vous
en train de laisser faire ?".
Ce que certains d'entre nous,
ici, essaient de faire.
Moi, je suis dans ce que m'a appris
Aron lui-même, ses lectures
et les amis autour de lui.
C'est qu'on doit être
extrêmement vigilants
sur ce qu'il se passe
et essayer de redonner
un peu de colonne vertébrale
à la façon de gérer le monde.
La principale leçon
qu'il faut garder d'Aron
dans cette période
très trouble où nous sommes,
c'est la compréhension réaliste
de ce qui est devant nous,
sans se cacher
et en appelant un chat un chat.
Et deuxièmement, avoir le courage
de dire : "Il faut qu'on fasse ça."
Un exemple et après, je me tais.
Quand on est dans une situation
où la guerre est de retour
en Europe depuis deux ans,
que c'est catastrophique,
qu'on tire des milliers d'obus
tous les jours,
6000 par jour en Ukraine.
Les Russes, beaucoup plus.
Quand on voit l'état
de notre industrie d'armement,
des budgets de défense
qui ont été votés,
y compris la loi de programmation
militaire française...
-On n'est pas préparés ?
-On a l'impression
d'avoir des lunettes noires,
de ne pas voir et de ne pas
se préparer au monde tel qu'il est.
Et ça, c'est grave.
Je pense qu'Aron aurait écrit
des trucs très durs
comme il l'avait fait
lors de la crise de Cuba.
Voilà, c'est la réalité.
-Jean-Claude Casanova.
-Nous avons publié
dans Commentaire un article d'Aron
qui est une conférence
qu'il a prononcée en 1969
et que je trouve
d'une remarquable actualité.
En 69, Pompidou vient
de prendre le pouvoir en France,
Aron a critiqué la politique
étrangère du général de Gaulle
à l'égard de l'Union soviétique
de 64 à la mort
du général de Gaulle.
Une politique
qui avait d'ailleurs été adulée
par la réinvasion
de la Tchécoslovaquie
en 1968.
Alors, que dit Aron en 1969 ?
Il dit :
"La puissance nucléaire soviétique
oblige l'Europe à être protégée
"par la puissance
nucléaire américaine."
L'Europe peut se satisfaire
de cette situation.
Elle est confortable,
mais regrettable.
Elle est confortable
parce qu'on dépense
beaucoup moins pour l'armement
puisque les Etats-Unis
le font à notre place.
Regrettable parce que
l'Europe perd sa souveraineté
et son existence historique.
Et si vous transposez
à la situation actuelle,
dans la situation actuelle,
l'Europe est faible
conventionnellement
vis-à-vis de la Russie,
alors que nous sommes
quatre fois plus peuplés,
dotés d'une puissance industrielle
supérieure à celle de la Russie.
Donc, nous pourrions avoir
une dissuasion conventionnelle
supérieure à celle de la Russie.
Et Aron a toujours soutenu
le nucléaire militaire français
et le nucléaire militaire anglais.
Explicitement, dans son article,
il laisse entendre que l'Europe
pourrait également se donner
une dissuasion nucléaire.
L'Europe sera donc souveraine
lorsqu'elle aura
une dissuasion nucléaire
et dissuasion conventionnelle.
Dans cet article,
il y a un profond regret.
"L'Europe veut-elle rester
au balcon de l'Histoire ?"
C'est une expression d'Aron.
Ou l'Europe veut-elle
être pour partie protégée
par des puissances
extérieures, qui,
puisque l'élection
de Trump se profile,
pourraient cesser
d'être protectrices ?
-Sylvie Bermann,
à qui la faute, alors ?
Et en même temps, est-ce qu'Aron
a influencé
la diplomatie française ?
-Comme je le disais tout à l'heure,
je crois que beaucoup
de diplomates sont devenus aroniens
parce que c'était la raison,
la logique, effectivement.
Oui, c'est une vision du monde.
Maintenant,
en ce qui concerne l'action,
c'est vrai qu'il y a
une faiblesse européenne.
Ce n'est pas du fait de la France.
Même le président Macron a poussé
pour une défense européenne,
une autonomie stratégique.
Mais on se heurte à d'autres pays.
Quant à la dissuasion nucléaire,
il avait été évoqué
la possibilité pour la France
de partager, justement,
dissuasion nucléaire.
Mais certains pays
sont profondément antinucléaires,
même antinucléaires civils.
-Oui, je confirme.
-Donc, ça...
Ils changeront, on l'espère.
Mais en tout cas,
ça prendra du temps.
On voit arriver Trump,
c'est une probabilité très forte.
On ne sait pas si, in fine,
c'est ce qui se passera.
Est-ce qu'on s'y prépare ? Non.
On commente,
on déplore,
mais on ne s'y prépare pas vraiment.
-Ca veut dire quoi,
"s'y préparer" ?
Avoir un budget de défense
bien plus important ?
-Un budget de défense
plus important, mais également,
avoir une base industrielle
de la défense,
des capacités d'action.
-Mais savez-vous...
Pardon, je coupe, mais...
Juste un mot.
La France, l'Angleterre,
l'Allemagne, aujourd'hui,
c'est moins de 200 chars de combat
en état de marche.
Chacun.
-On le voit,
puisqu'ils n'ont pas la possibilité
d'armer l'Ukraine.
-On en est réduits à ça
au bout de 30 ans de désarmement
budgétaire unilatéral.
C'est un exemple.
-Poursuivez.
-La décision a été prise
de fournir un million d'obus
à l'Ukraine.
On en a fourni 300 000 seulement.
-En un an.
-Oui.
-On devait fabriquer
un million en un an.
-Oui et on en a fabriqué 300 000.
Donc, il y a ce problème-là.
-Pourquoi
en a-t-on fabriqué 300 000 ?
Parce qu'une industrie de défense,
pour engager une chaîne
de production d'obus
ou de quoi que ce soit d'autre,
a besoin de contrats à long terme
pour acheter des équipements
et pour engager des gens.
Or, les budgets actuels
de l'Europe sont insuffisants
pour relancer
les sites de production.
C'est pour ça qu'on n'a plus
d'industrie de défense.
Donc, tout ce que vous entendez,
pardon, c'est du pipeau.
Par rapport à la gravité
de ce qu'il se passe en face
et de ce qui peut arriver
demain aux Etats-Unis,
l'Europe est encore plus faible
de ce qu'elle n'a jamais été.
-Retournons à Aron.
Le constat, vous l'avez fait
sur l'insuffisante
préparation de l'Europe
qui explique par ailleurs
pourquoi cette Europe
n'est pas une puissance.
Raymond Aron disait
à l'époque de la guerre froide :
"paix impossible,
guerre improbable".
J'aimerais que vous explicitiez
ce que ça veut dire.
Est-ce qu'on est dans un retour
à la guerre froide ?
Parce qu'on se retrouve
dans un contexte
plus conflictuel que jamais.
-C'est effectivement
la formule qu'il avait utilisée
dans un livre qui date de 47
pour définir la situation,
avant même qu'il y ait
l'équilibre de la terreur
qui a rendu cette formule
encore plus juste.
"Paix impossible", pourquoi ?
Parce que les deux systèmes
idéologiques et politiques
étaient irréductiblement opposés
et qu'il n'y avait pas
de compromis ou d'accord possibles.
Et "guerre improbable"
parce qu'effectivement...
-Mais la guerre est là, maintenant.
-Non mais ça, c'est l'explication
de la situation de la guerre froide
à la fin des années 40
et au début des années 50.
Ensuite, après la chute
de l'Union soviétique,
on s'est retrouvé dans un système
où l'on a cru
que la paix était perpétuelle
et la guerre était impossible.
C'était une illusion pure.
Il suffisait de voir
ce qu'il se passait dans la réalité,
notamment avec une Russie
sous l'autorité de Vladimir Poutine
qui a été en réalité
en guerre permanente.
La guerre est au principe
du régime de Vladimir Poutine.
Et Aron ne se serait
certainement pas trompé
sur la nature réelle
du régime russe.
Et aujourd'hui,
nous sommes dans un système
que je définirai ainsi :
la paix est de nouveau impossible.
Nous avons de nouveau
des systèmes politiques
qui sont en guerre,
en lutte à mort,
avec la Chine de Xi Jinping,
avec la Russie de Poutine,
avec aussi des théocraties.
On l'oublie toujours,
mais l'Iran, l'Afghanistan
et les djihadistes qui vont avec.
Donc, la paix est impossible,
mais la guerre est omniprésente.
On sous-estime le fait
que depuis 1945,
il n'y a jamais eu autant
d'Etats en guerre qu'aujourd'hui.
Les Européens
ne veulent pas le voir.
Cela a été rappelé par Pierre.
C'est incroyable.
On a un président de la République
qui utilise
les mots de "réarmement",
mais qui n'en fait rien.
Là, c'est une autre chose
que nous dit Aron.
Quand les mots jurent autant
avec les choses
et la réalité de ce qu'on fait,
ça se finit toujours très mal.
Et donc, il est très important
pour les Européens,
mais aussi pour la France,
de remettre les mots en face
avec les faits et la politique.
L'économie de guerre,
pour le coup, elle existe en Russie.
Et elle n'existe pas chez nous.
-Merci.
Pierre Lellouche, là-dessus ?
-Sur "paix impossible,
guerre improbable",
je crois que l'équation demeure.
Ni la Russie ni les Etats-Unis
ne veulent d'un affrontement direct.
D'ailleurs, ils se gardent bien
de dépasser le seuil
d'une guerre
par procuration en Ukraine.
Mais ce qui est
beaucoup plus problématique,
c'est que maintenant, il y a
beaucoup d'acteurs dans le système.
Une des conséquences de la guerre
en Ukraine, que je trouve
complètement
absurde depuis le début...
On aurait pu l'éviter,
on a choisi de ne pas l'éviter.
Les Américains ont hésité,
y sont allés...
On est dans un système qui...
-C'est quand même
un pays occupé.
-C'est ni le premier ni le dernier.
-C'est un pays occupé
qui a près de 20 pour 100
de son territoire.
Vous savez bien que l'impérialisme
russe est d'abord territorial.
C'est une leçon de l'Histoire.
-Mais la question...
-Ce n'est pas notre sujet.
-Justement, Aron aurait
probablement essayé de comprendre
le pourquoi du comment
de cette guerre.
C'est ce qui n'a pas été fait.
Je dis que cette guerre est d'abord
une guerre émotionnelle.
On y est engagé
pour un tas de raisons.
-Des milliers de morts.
Bon.
-L'Ukraine
est une ligne de fracture.
-On ne va pas
cristalliser là-dessus.
Parlons plutôt de...
-Ce qu'allait dire Pierre Lellouche
et qu'on partage tous,
c'est qu'avec la guerre en Ukraine
et les événements du 7 octobre,
il y a un effet
de libération de la violence.
-Ce que j'essaye de dire,
c'est qu'avec cette affaire,
nous avons tous réussi,
y compris Poutine...
Je ne suis pas là
pour dire qu'il n'a pas envahi.
La façon dont cette affaire
a été gérée,
c'est qu'à la fin de la journée,
nous avons réalisé le cauchemar
de Kissinger et sans doute d'Aron,
qui est de fabriquer une alliance
entre la Russie et la Chine
avec deux autres puissances
nucléaires potentielles
encore plus dingues,
l'Iran et la Corée du Nord.
Du point de vue
des intérêts stratégiques
de l'Europe, cette situation
est probablement la pire possible.
A partir de là,
il va falloir essayer
de désescalader
et de trouver la solution.
-Si vous le voulez bien,
revenons à Aron.
Il nous reste peu de temps.
Que chacun dise un mot
là-dessus. Je sais que....
Le cosmopolitisme d'Aron
en faisait un lecteur
aussi passionné de Thucydide
que de Marx.
A votre avis, Raymond Aron
était-il aussi sujet au doute
et réceptif aux contradictions
dont Nietzsche disait
que c'était un principe de sagesse ?
Pierre Manent, très brièvement.
C'est une question importante,
mais ça nous permet de conclure
et que chacun
dise un mot
sur la personnalité d'Aron
qu'on voudrait être trop raisonnable
par rapport au côté trop rêveur
de Jean-Paul Sartre.
En un mot.
Je sais que c'est difficile,
mais ça nous permet
de cerner le personnage.
Etait-il sujet au doute ?
-Je pense qu'il...
Il avait toujours peur
de se tromper.
C'est pourquoi il se trompait
moins que les autres.
-C'est une très bonne formule.
-Mais il était passionné
et il le savait.
C'est pourquoi il faisait
un si grand effort pour surmonter
sa passion. Pour moi,
Aron, c'est... Comment dire ?
Si j'ose dire, c'est
le grand citoyen par excellence.
Il est mu
par la passion du bien commun
et par un désir passionné
de comprendre
les ressorts de l'histoire humaine.
Comment nous nous débrouillons
pour conduire ces vies
qui sont à la fois calamiteuses
et parfois, splendides.
C'est ainsi que...
...que je le vois.
-Jean-Claude Casanova,
un homme qui doute ?
-Il a beaucoup étudié Marx,
mais il aurait préféré
étudier autre chose.
Il a beaucoup étudié Marx
parce qu'à partir de Marx,
étrangement, d'ailleurs,
l'Union soviétique était devenue
une puissance impérialiste
qui dominait
la moitié de l'Europe,
la moitié de Berlin,
la moitié de l'Europe, absolument.
Le grand vainqueur
de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
c'est Staline qui a,
d'une certaine façon,
donné à la Russie
une puissance qu'elle n'avait
jamais connue dans son histoire.
Cela au nom d'une religion
créée à partir de Marx.
-Et qui ne devait pas
s'appliquer à la Russie.
-Il l'a beaucoup étudié,
mais il aurait préféré autre chose.
-Un mot là-dessus ?
-L'homme du doute, oui,
puisque la plupart des gens
font de leurs mémoires
un exercice d'autocélébration.
Les mémoires d'Aron,
c'est comment il utilise
son esprit critique pour revoir
sa trajectoire et sa pensée.
L'autre mot, c'est générosité,
y compris avec ses adversaires.
Non seulement
il les respecte, mais...
C'est celui
qui réhabilite le vrai Sartre
face à Benny Lévy.
-Absolument.
-Merci.
Je suis désolé d'interrompre
cette conversation
fort intéressante,
notamment sur un personnage
aussi passionnant
que Raymond Aron,
mais le temps imparti est écoulé.
Je voudrais vous présenter
une brève bibliographie.
On peut retrouver
toute l'oeuvre de Raymond Aron :
"Paix et guerre
entre les nations",
publié chez Calmann-Lévy,
ses mémoires chez Robert Laffont,
"L'opium des intellectuels",
enfin, tout ce que vous voulez.
Nicolas Baverez,
vous avez également publié
une biographie de Raymond Aron :
"Un moraliste
au temps des idéologies."
C'est paru chez Perrin.
Qu'avez-vous voulu montrer ?
En un mot.
J'ai voulu montrer
précisément que le courage
n'est pas réservé
aux hommes d'action.
Il peut aussi être
celui des intellectuels.
C'est le fameux discours
de Soljenitsyne,
"Le déclin du courage".
Avec Aron, quelqu'un a montré
qu'il n'y a pas
de déclin du courage.
-Merci. Sylvie Bermann.
Vous avez été ambassadeur
à Pékin et à Moscou.
Vous avez publié
"Une vie de diplomate".
Ca vous a beaucoup servi
d'être à la fois
à Pékin et à Moscou
pour comprendre le monde
comme spectatrice engagée ?
-Oui, bien sûr...
-Diplomate engagée.
-Ce sont des acteurs
déterminants et surtout,
j'ai connu des périodes charnières.
J'ai connu la fin
de l'Union soviétique
à l'époque de Gorbatchev,
la fin de la guerre froide,
j'ai connu la période Poutine.
Ensuite, j'ai été étudiante
en Chine en 76,
à la fin de la révolution
culturelle.
-Vous racontez ça
merveilleusement.
-J'ai connu Deng Xiaoping,
Xi Jinping.
Oui, c'est fondamental
pour comprendre le monde.
-Jean-Claude Casanova,
vous avez publié
de nombreux livres,
dont "De Giscard à Mitterrand".
Là, c'est contemporain,
presque contemporain,
de Mitterrand.
Vous trouvez
que les hommes politiques
ont été influencés
par Raymond Aron ?
Un peu, passionnément,
pas du tout ?
-Je crois, dans la période...
Giscard, d'une certaine façon.
Il lisait beaucoup Aron.
Et Pompidou,
d'une certaine façon aussi.
Et de Gaulle, au moment
de l'Alliance atlantique.
Mais je voudrais
rappeler un mot d'Aron
parce que Sartre
avait dit un jour :
"Aron est admirateur".
Et Sartre disait ça avec mépris
parce qu'il n'était pas
spontanément admirateur.
Et Aron invoquait toujours
la formule d'Alain :
"L'admiration
est la consolation des forts."
C'est-à-dire que la capacité
d'admirer est une forme
de générosité,
tandis que le ressentiment
crée le besoin de dénigrer.
-Merci de le rappeler.
Pierre Manent, vous avez publié
"Pascal et la proposition
chrétienne."
On n'a pas le temps d'en parler.
Mais vous diriez
qu'Aron était pascalien ?
Cela vous choque de dire ça ?
-Non.
Ca ne me choque pas.
Tocqueville, qui était quand même
une de ses grandes lectures,
était explicitement pascalien.
En même temps, je pense qu'Aron
avait respect pour la religion,
respect pour le christianisme.
Mais ce n'était pas une âme
naturellement religieuse.
Je ne dirais
pas que c'était un homme
qui était tourmenté
par la question religieuse,
mais à coup sûr, comme il le dit
de façon assez mémorable,
sa détestation
des religions séculières
lui a donné un certain respect
pour les religions régulières
dont parlait Nicolas.
-Pierre Lellouche,
vous avez écrit
"Une guerre sans fin".
Il semblerait que nous soyons
dans une conflictualisation
sans fin. Vous partagez
ce pessimisme-là ?
-Je suis sur un autre livre,
justement, sur la phase suivante.
Malheureusement,
l'Institut stratégique de Londres
a dénombré en 2023 183 conflits,
hors la guerre de Gaza.
183 conflits. Donc,
on est en plein dedans.
-Merci.
Je voudrais vous remercier, madame,
messieurs,
d'avoir participé
à cette émission.
Je voudrais vous remercier
l'équipe de LCP.
Et avant de nous quitter,
je vous soumets
cette pensée de Raymond Aron.
"La liberté est l'essence
de la culture occidentale,
"le fondement de sa réussite,
le secret de son étendue,
"et de son influence."
Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA